in this video we will study about the
female reproductive system the female
reproductive system can be divided in
two parts the external sex organs and
the internal sex organs before beginning
make sure to subscribe meThe simplified
on youtube for all the upcoming videos
on topics like spermatogenesis male
reproductive system or genesis and much
more so first let's talk about the
external sex organs also known as vulva
in case of females the external sex
organs consist of the Mons pubis which
is a soft mound of fatty tissue in front
of the pubic bone the word Mons means
Mound and the pubis refers to pubic bone
the word labia is derived from Latin
word which means lip labia majora are
the outer folder the skin that protect
the other external reproductive organs
they also contain sweat and the oil
glands labia minora lie inside the labia
majora and surround the vaginal as well
as the urethral openings the two labia
minora meet at the front and form the
clitoris which is a highly sensitive as
it contains many nerve endings clitoris
is homologous to glans penis in case of
males the central part is the vulva
vestibule which contains the vaginal as
well as you little openings let's study
the internal sex organs of the female
reproductive system
the internal sex organs consist of the
vagina and the cervical canal to
fallopian tubes the central uterus and a
pair of ovaries let's first talk about
the vagina and the cervical canal the
vagina is a fibromuscular canal which is
10 centimeters long it is lined by
non-keratinized stratified squamous
epithelium the vagina provides a path
for menstrual blood and fetus to leave
the body the vaginal mucosa glands
provide lubrication it also receives the
male sex organs and the sperms the
cervix is the lower cylindrical part of
the uterus it is lined by column inner
cells it also contains numerous mucous
glands which help in production of mucus
for lubrication the cervix prepares the
sperms for fertilization and also delays
several folds during the childbirth now
let's talk about the fallopian tubes
each fallopian tube is a 10 centimeter
long hollow organ which is made up of
four paths the infundibulum is the
lateral end of the fallopian tube to
which numerous finger ship projections
known as a film reel are attached the
fimbria pick up the oocyte once it is
released from the ovary the ampulla is a
central dilated part of the fallopian
tube and it is the most common site for
the fertilization the medial end of the
fallopian tube is the islamists which
connects the tube to the uterus now
let's study about the uterus
the uterus is also known as a womb or
the childbearing organ the fertilized
egg implants in the uterus and through a
series of changes grows into a fetus the
uterus is 7.5 centimeters long
five centimeters broad and 2.5
centimeters thick it is made up of the
following parts the fundus body the
cavity of the uterus which is lined by
mucous membrane and coronal or the
corners of the uterus to which fallopian
tubes are attached let's have a brief
look about the walls of the uterus the
wall of the uterus is made up of three
layers very material myometrium and the
inner endometrium pari materia ms a thin
layer of epithelial cells that covers
the uterus from outside it is the
visceral peritoneum of the uterus the
myometrium is a central thickest layer
made up of smooth muscle cells it has a
very important role in childbirth as it
undergoes a series of contraptions and
relaxations which propels the fetus
outside
it is main site for development of
fibroids and adenomyosis endometrium is
the innermost and most active layer of
the uterus it undergoes a series of
changes throughout the month under the
influence of hormones estrogen and
progesterone it is a site for
development of endometrial hyperplasia
and cancer
the ovary is the main reproductive organ
which is 4 into 3 into 2 centimeters in
dimension the ovary has two main
functions first it produces the female
eggs also known as asides second it also
produces a female reproductive hormones
the estrogen and progesterone looking at
the cross-section of the ovary it is
made up of the central medulla and the
outer part known as the cortex the
medulla consists of the dense connective
tissue
it also contains all the blood vessels
nerves and the lymphatics the cortex
consists of numerous ovarian follicles
in various stages of development
these ovarian follicles secrete estrogen
when ovarian follicle matures and
releases a female egg it becomes the
corpus luteum which secretes the
progesterone so this was a brief
overview about the female reproductive
system thank you so much for watching
this video like our channel on YouTube
for all the upcoming videos and make
sure to like our channel on Facebook for
flashcards and upcoming notifications